there are new allegations as sexual
misconduct continued at Fox News Channel
years after the revelations that led to
the departure of CEO Roger Ailes former
White House correspondent and anchor
Edie Henry is among those mentioned in
the new complaint he was fired three
weeks ago shortly after the new claims
against him first surfaced the lawsuit
also accuses current on-air
personalities including Tucker Carlson
and Sean Hannity of sexual harassment
the network says those claims are false
patently frivolous and utterly devoid of
any merit first on CBS this morning
national correspondent Jericka Duncan
spoke to the two women making the
allegations including one who says Edie
Henry raped her drinka good morning what
are these women tell you good morning
you know Tony they said they feel
relieved but yet still scared I spoke to
Jennifer Eckhart and Cathy aroo-whoo
described a workplace where they say
abuse was routine and even expected a
warning to our viewers some of the
allegations you're about to hear you may
find very disturbing after we met and we
had our photo taken together he messaged
me Wow
you are way more beautiful in person
Jennifer ACOG says her connection to
then Fox News correspondent edy Henry
began in 2014 when she was a production
assistant as a 24 year old girl when the
the chief White House correspondent
follows you on Twitter
you you you know you get stars in your
eyes but Eckhart says those stars
quickly faded in a lawsuit filed Monday
she accuses Henry of violently raping
her in 2017 while she was helpless and
restrained in metal handcuffs and says
Henry performs sadistic acts on her that
left her injured bruised and battered
with bloody wrists would you
characterize the relationship you were
in with ed Henry as mainly abusive
absolutely without question I felt that
he had the power to derail me to destroy
me to ruin my career and I just I didn't
have a voice until now
eckhart alleges Henry asked her to be
his sex slave and threatened
punishment and retaliation if she didn't
comply in response to those claims an
attorney for ed Henry said the evidence
in this case will demonstrate that Miss
Eckhart initiated and completely
encouraged a consensual relationship was
there ever a time at Fox that you felt
safe I think it's safe to say that I was
paralyzed by fear when I was working
there I don't know how you could call to
continue to cultivate and foster an
environment that rewards sexual
predators consistently year after year I
don't want anyone else to feel that way
Kathy Aroo a co plaintiff in the lawsuit
says she hopes that speaking out will
create change up in network she alleges
she was sexually harassed by at least
four men there I kind of got numb to it
I thought it was perfectly fine to
receive pornographic images and gifts I
thought that was normal for a male
anchor to do to send pornographic images
yeah just to send you pornographic
images yep a roué claimed she was
targeted by some of the network's
biggest stars
she says Tucker Carlson featured her on
his show less after she refused his
sexual advances she also alleges that
Sean Hannity completely unsolicited
threw $100 on his anchor desk demanding
that someone take her out on a date for
drinks attorney Michael Willemijn
represents both women what's most
troubling about this lawsuit is that
it's occurring in 2020 it's not
occurring in the Ailes regime when
former Fox and Friends host gretchen
carlson won her historic sexual
harassment lawsuit against Fox News and
then CEO Roger Ailes in 2016 some
believe the workplace conditions would
improve not a roof some of the men
complained that there were so many
meetings that they had to go to on how
to speak to women and how not to
sexually harass Fox News says it
concluded a ruse allegations were
baseless after an independent
investigation responding in part by
saying we take all claims of harassment
misconduct and retaliation seriously the
lawsuit also alleges that Fox News
higher-ups were made aware that other
women had filed complaints about sexual
misconduct regarding at Henry but the
network says there were no claims about
sexual misconduct on and Henry as early
as 2017 other than the claims that
Eckhart recently made now Jennifer
Eckart tells us she was fired from Fox
News this past June Tony my opening
interviews there'd Rika thank you very
much